president donald trump's
neighbors mar-a-lago are taking legal
action to try to convince them to leave
trump's florida neighbors uh are not
happy with them wanting to be their
permanent resident according to
washington post
neighbors reportedly wrote a letter to
palm beach authorities and the u.s
secret service saying trump had no legal
rights to live there full-time citing
legal precedent over
from an agreement that trump signed in
1993 when he sought to
turn what he had been a residence into a
private club under the terms of the
agreement no guest is permitted to stay
in the club for
more than three non-consecutive day
periods during one one year
according to the post the letter says
palm beach authorities should promptly
notify trump he is not allowed to live
in mar-a-lago to avoid an embarrassing
situation
in which a former president had to be
evicted
that's it you like the story
dania likes this story a lot
opinions adam thoughts i'm trying to get
kai this thing over here
okay what did you say epstein i like him
he likes young girls
yeah sorry what do you say about what
they're doing guys do you have an
opinion on this you look like you want
to say something yeah i
just sent kai something yes i do have an
opinion go ahead guys
check your text though though guys tell
me if you know that signed in contract
then i don't think there's too much he
can do
i mean obviously he'll probably try to
fight it but
if it's signed it's signed
here's where i think trump should live i
think trump should live
in the state where he received
the highest percentage of the votes
that's where i think he should move no
more mar-a-lago i'm sorry you need to go
to your base so he needs to go to either
wyoming alabama west virginia
that's his people that's where he needs
to go if he loves those people he loves
him so much that's where i think he
should live
no more with mar-a-lago i think and i'm
not even saying that disrespectfully i
mean that
you love these people go live stop
what stop it hillary clinton she won the
most votes in new york she moved to new
york
yeah obama yeah i registered to vote so
that i could vote against your guys
trump should go live in west virginia
that's where i think you should go no
more mar-a-lago for you
double down the double down when i when
i was at breakers a couple months ago i
asked
a lot of people how do you guys feel
about you know trump being here how do
you feel about trump being here i feel
about trump being here
it was mixed feelings on what a lot of
people said some of them
who were on the higher ups they said
look we kind of don't mind him because
he
increased the value here a lot of people
want a movie i want to look at trump's
house that's on the market right now 135
million
went through the realtor was a very good
friend with trump for the last 32 years
while i'm speaking to him
uh uh steve wynn called you know we're
having a conversation all this stuff so
we look at the
beautiful home 70 million dollars of art
in there to be able to
get the audience to be more excited
about wanting to make a bid on this 135
million
home so there are those that say he did
very good for
the city okay to bring mar-a-lago and do
what he did
there's those that say when he's here
road suck transportation i can't get
through there's a three-hour wait
because when he wants to go to the beach
the secret service goes and i'm so sick
of it because i can't take my route if i
want to get home i don't make it on time
there's only one way for me to make it
home it takes me two hours to get home
so there is because if you've been to
palm beach and know how the city is
you literally only can go there from a
couple different places it's not like
they're so
it's like trying to get off trying to
get off the freeway in new jersey
understand
what they're saying i actually
understand what they're saying don't
forget jared kushner and
ivanka bought a house on one of those
islands down there so
uh there's a part of it that i
understand for how the community is
being affected by it
the other part of it is the guy's guys
he's going to go want to live wherever
he wants to live if we just say you
can't live in a place
you know he's going to find a way to
revoke this and figure out a way to live
anywhere he wants to live the guy has
enough money to go buy a house anywhere
but he likes palm beach he likes
mar-a-lago who knows what's going to
happen with what he's going to do
um i hope when whatever i say right now
i hope
whatever takes place next you know as
biden you know
you got the uh electoral college came
out you know uh december 14th that they
came out oh it's official it's this it's
that okay finally
mcconnell came out and putin called and
all these guys are calling okay so we're
going in this direction
i hope i hope i hope
that both the media like the other day
jake tapper came out and said what
thinks trump's done good
okay he actually said a couple things
that trump has done good on his
administration
sort of sarcastically but he did give
him credit in the beginning he did give
him a little bit of credit
i hope there's some of that going on
because
you know that could also calm him down
for him to go away and just kind of do
his own thing okay i hope the media
also doesn't constantly poke the bear
over and over and over again which i
don't think that's going to
i don't think that's going to happen i
don't think he's going to call him
number two let me give the number two
i hope he does a little bit in the
transition i don't think he's going to
because he and his base
fully believe there was fraud which
there's a lot of proof of it you can see
a lot of proof of it
but in court it didn't hold weight and
to be able to have
your proof go to the next level you got
to be able to get the justices to side
with you you got to be able to get some
of these governors so i want to turn
things around you've got to be able to
get some of these
local justices and unfortunately it's
battle after battle after battle you
keep saying
we keep saying proof and there's a lot
of people out there that believe that
there was fraud cool i respect your
opinion
but at what point when every single
court says no
no there wasn't at what point was every
single
state uh governor uh
secretary of state remember how many at
what point did they say all right like
you lost how many liberal fans of
hillary clinton who will love hillary
clinton can you convince that she lost
the election to trump
how many so there's actually a number on
that 30 percent of people
30 of democrats were thinking that there
was
illegitimate 30 okay there you go 75
of republicans so more than double
that's normal though that's not a big
number that's
what do you mean 30 of democrats
basically said
no it's illegitimate we don't believe
that trump's a president 75
of republicans now that's not that said
what that that is illegitimate yeah i
saw that i saw okay so that's not even
close is what i'm saying
but i i s that that just means there are
more true believers of trump than they
were true believers of hillary which
makes sense to me because that's fine
trump is a bigger personality but at one
point
but at what point do you say all right
like the supreme court
every single court every state every
four years somebody loses and whoever
loses
is emotional give it time okay you're
saying a lot of is an emotion not logic
uh yeah i i think everything right now
quite frankly if i was if i was the die
hard republican fan right
if i'm the die-hard trump guy you know
my number one focus is if i'm a die-hard
trump
trump fan georgia that's my number one
focus if i'm a die-hard principles of
the right your number one priority ought
to be georgia
we shouldn't have called in to question
the integrity
of kemp no the integrity of elections
yeah because you're because you're going
to have a harder time getting out the
vote in georgia
because of this yeah in my opinion the
final thought here
he was calling it a rigged election in
2016. he somehow won
right now it's another rigged election
in 2020 he so
what's going to happen they don't they
don't bother him with him wanting to
live in mar-a-lago if he wants to live
in a place like this i hope they
or in westwood yeah or you know west
virginia's got a better song than palm
beach i don't know
a song in palm beach that goes as good
as the one from west virginia
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye